if you're looking to downsize your house
and maybe help cut some costs
living in a tiny home may be the
solution for you
and if you're curious about this unique
concept of living various tiny homes
are on display at the home improvement
and backyard expo at world center market
builders say we don't realize how much
excess extra space we have in our
traditional houses so this may be an
idea for maybe someone looking
to utilize every bit of their home or
maybe someone looking
to buy for the very first time at some
point we stopped building
starter homes it was a home there was a
one bedroom maybe a two bedroom home and
most home developers just don't build
them anymore so
we are now bringing back the starter
home the one bedroom
home or the studio home that can be
lived in and
bought at a very affordable price well
tiny home costs start
at about 60 thousand dollars if you'd
like to check it out while the x
it's over at the exponent runs until
sunday so cute aren't